a guy writes me says man you got  misspelled words all in that book  i'm like yeah yeah what so what where  are they  123 128 134 165 120  i'm like yeah yeah and bad grammar too  i'm like  yeah what's your point dude i don't  what's your point man why you keep  telling me that  he's like cause man you got misspelled  words in a book it's a best seller  okay so it ain't best written okay you  know what i'm not now  this word just so any nobody unders i  don't want you to think that that's a  cuss word  the word look it up in the dictionary  means a complainer a wine or an excuse  maker  i wear a little band on my pen here on  my wrist here  it's a little black band and it says  champions  dominate and on the other side  don't be a little